three two
[Music]
one
e
[Laughter]
I'm in the flow
yes welcome Aaron ABY thank you for
having me man pleasure to be here hell
yes we've met already but our third
density bodies got to meet today yes we
got to meet in flesh we did an episode
like two years ago yeah online that was
a good one
and I like how you pulled up the ASMR
nonsense that I had up on the YouTube
channel and you were like what is this
and then we just sillly s sillly wanted
to start the episode that way and it was
actually what it was advertised to be it
was 30 minutes of ASMR nonsense I was
like we should start to pod like
this yes just drop right into flow it
was funny when you were like was there
was there someone that taught you this
and I I was like it's just been a
freaking goon since Young n and it's
just feels great your own soul taught
you yeah I thought like a Buddhist monk
was like if you make silly noises for 30
minutes you'll enter the enlightened
state or
something yes I'll try
anything I'll try anything to be what I
already am yes what a paradox
huh we so we have uh it's fun coming
together like this now um also after
these apparent years of continued
apparent years apparent years yeah of
continued um now our focus seems to be
uh more um you know Finding what was
never
lost and now like building new Earth mhm
and so that's what we have on the on the
episode that we're excited to talk about
and yeah
um let's uh let's let's jump in and
let's let's see well actually you know
what I want I want to start with I
actually want to start with we have like
we have money truth new Earth we have
all these things we want to talk about I
want to actually start with the truth
piece because I want to start with like
kind of like that as the foundation as
we talk about CU it's always where it's
coming from right so we can talk about
the concepts of new Earth and whatnot
but where is it coming from is it still
coming from a sense of lack or
separation or or whatever or if it's not
and so which it never really is um so
let's start let's start with that so um
you know I when I when I said there a
moment ago that you know um finding what
was never lost you were like yes MH so
can you play on that for us for for a
little bit because you also do so in
that sense there's like no path in that
sense finding what was never lost
there's no path and so but at the same
time there is an apparent path like for
example there's students of like 4D
University and whatnot and things like
that so how how do that how do you see
all of that yeah well in the not in the
new Earth conversation but in like the
individual spiritual Ascension context
um there are there are archetypal paths
Buddhism Hinduism mystical Christianity
dosm that many can use to reach the same
destination but there isn't a path in
the sense that no two people are going
to have had the exact same Journey you
know they're all completely unique and
different maybe they they used the same
disciplines they meditated on the same
Concepts but the actual unfoldment of
the evolution is totally different for
everyone so that's how where like two
things can be true the dualistic and the
non-dualistic but in the in the context
of the new Earth which is what we're
honing in on today you know this is my
greatest passion right now to help
Humanity survive through this hellacious
dark KN of the Soul that's going through
and to be of service and help the planet
shift into the fourth density and and I
think where the truth Begins for
Humanity right now is the Awakening to
natural law which was what was never
lost that you mentioned that there is an
underlying law system or law form in the
universe we call it natural law that is
unbreakable and irrevocable and eternal
there's you can violate it all you want
it it allows you to violate it but not
by escaping the consequences of doing so
right and we call that Karma so so
Humanity has built up a lot of karma
over tens of thousands of years that
we're now paying off because we've been
violating natural law like crazy and uh
what we'll get into today with the money
truth Freedom conversation is how that
violation of natural law has manifested
as what we see today as our legal system
and our monetary system every system
humanity is currently um that Humanity
has currently made and is enslaving
Humanity uh Humanity made the systems
that are now enslaving it the monetary
system the legal system and that's
because we've been violating natural law
and you know the basis of natural law is
what Jesus said um love the Lord your
God and love your neighbor as yourself
whatever you do to another will be done
unto you so all attack is really self-
attack all judgment is really self-
judgment Humanity has not figured that
out yet right so we've created a world
that reflects that ignorance and we are
are basically enslaved to that world now
and that's the Catalyst for our
Awakening as well but the Awakening is
painful right you have to wake up to all
the Shadows inside and all the darkness
and the things you feel shame for and
guilt for and you have to bring light
and healing to those parts of you so I
feel like as a collective humanity is at
that part of our uh Awakening where
we've just realized we have a lot of
Shadows that need healing and they're
starting to manifest and we're we
haven't yet figured F out that the right
way to heal those shadows and move
forward and evolve is by forgiving them
you know and having compassion and
understanding we're still trying to like
make reparations for what was done in
the past your forefathers did this to my
forefather so you pay up we're keeping
the war going right down the generations
but it's it's the combination of all
that Insanity manifesting all that
conflict and division manifesting that
starts to wake us up to go there's got
to be a better way of living I actually
love that line because if you're if
you're familiar with A Course in
Miracles mhm then you probably know the
story of Helen shukman who channeled the
course she was living uh she was working
at
um is it Harvard or Columbia University
and her and her colleague Dr William
thatford were in the midst of this like
political turmoil amongst the faculty at
the college there's all this Division I
think there was a lot of political
ideology battling and stuff and they got
so sick of it and frustrated by it they
were like h chuckman said to Dr William
at the in a private meeting there's just
got to be a better way of doing this of
being together right there's got to be a
better way like
psychologically and that was the like
cry she put out into the universe that
the Universe answered by channeling A
Course in Miracles in response to that
question of there's got to be a better
way and so I think we're kind of saying
that now as a as a whole there's got to
be a better way and it's being manifest
as this Awakening to common law that's
started here in the States and Canada
mostly where we are realizing that the
actual law form called common law or the
law common for mankind that was
established by our forefathers and it's
the it's essentially the highest
jurisdiction of law it completely trumps
uh commercial law legal legalities it's
the highest law form of the land but
it's been swept aside by those in power
because it's what gives the people power
so over the course of time they've tried
to scr rub it from our memory it's
literally like a dystopian Sci-Fi show
or something they've erased our real
past from us they've taught us a wrong
version of American history that twists
it so that we keep putting our power in
the government's hands rather than
becoming our own power and standing
together and so this Awakening is really
amazing and I've gotten swept up into it
obviously because when you hear about
this you just can't not respond to it
with a total total body hell yes I'm all
in um I will be a living example of the
truth you
know
nice yeah yeah nice okay so all right so
on that on that first bit um
there's there's both what's already here
that's never lost and then there's the
apparent process mhm okay so then there
okay so there's an apparent process um
and it's it's actually quite funny even
that is been just undermined so much in
the conversations that have that have
been coming up more and more in the last
months is just like undermining that
there that there can be an attainment of
freedom and that there even is an entity
in the first place that can attain and
that there's already no entity and
there's already no loc locality and
there's already just Oneness that is
Pure Freedom innocence in this in this
beautiful appearance that that that it
is and so it's always fun to um to cut
and like undermine that sort of ah well
I'm not free yet
that dude we're about to get into this
conversation I'm telling you man I love
it oh and then there's everything else
that um that you shared which I'm
excited to hear more about um how you
how you've um kind of looked at what um
are the are the things that put the
put the apparent handcuffs on and also
cuz what I shared with you before we
started was that a lot of what what at
least what this is honed in on on
building is just like the future of just
decentralizing basic needs and allowing
people to be free in that um in that way
um and so basically never having like
waking up every day and never even
having to think about money never having
to think about shelter energy food water
every day is just waking up to Joy and
play yeah and that's like that's the
future within just some years hopefully
you can Homestead with all your basic
needs being met in these new Earth
communities so that's where all of my
like energy and focus along with the
show is there and then it was
interesting before the show you were
talking about how you have that focus
and then you also have the focus on
understanding the Old patterns of the
system that have um that have created
those that that appearance of of
shackles and how to in a way break free
from those so okay so so we'll have
those those themes all right
so so how about
um how how would you respond let's say
when you have let's start here how would
you respond let's say if we have
um you have a you have a good amount
right now of of those that are in like
Ford University right now as example and
when when when when there is the
question because you have um how often
are you are you hosting a um where it's
like a live 4D University session with
every Sunday every Sunday so and in
those sessions there can be a a a
question that is asked yeah right
because I've seen some of the videos
where you respond to the question that
are asked that you then put up on like
YouTube and
whatnot
so okay so how do you respond
when someone that is asking says that
you know I I I still I still have a
process I still have a path I still I'm
still not free I still I still need to
attain something in order to be free how
how do
you reflect back
there it's definitely unique to the
individual of course
but in general I I try to do my best to
let people be where they are to a
certain extent and not infringe on their
world too much but invite through
questions invite them to challenge their
world in the same way that I have
challenged mine you know and so those
you know it's Unique to whatever the
question is or what the life experience
they're talking about is but I really
like to go into the Catalyst of their
life experience and in fact we just
started doing that every month we do the
first Sunday of every month we do our
catalst Journal Workshop where um it's
kind of one of the practices we give in
4u where they Journal about their at the
end of the day they think back on their
day and they review what experiences
today challenged
me uh provoked negative emotions and
reactions in me and then they write out
oh um my spouse said this comment to me
and I responded back like this and then
I felt guilty about it they'll just
write it out you know practically
speaking and then they take it through
kind of the three disciplines of the
personality what is this experience
asking me to be aware of in myself what
is this experience asking me to love and
accept Within Myself and then to me
becoming the Creator is like
requalifying my thoughts about that
experience so let's say
um The Experience
provoked me feeling small or insecure in
some way uh self-devaluation
then I will I will take it into a kind
of quiet place within myself and find
the thought that feels like what I'm
thinking which is um I'm just not good
enough for example and so I'll say I
denounce the belief that I'm not good
enough and I affirm that I am good
enough or whatever way I want to affirm
the truth truth I always teach it has to
come from a real heart-c centered place
so um don't use my formula don't use the
montras I use unless they really
resonate but get quiet within and
whatever truth feels good when you
affirm it uh like I am abundant whatever
feels good whatever feels expansive
affirm that and if you can do that
you're sort of requalifying the energy
of that thought because we are the
creators right so whatever we're
thinking about and whatever we've
thought about in the past is qualif IED
with the record of how we felt about it
you know so if I felt negative about a
certain thing I've like saved that
negative idea in my infinite Memory Bank
Of Consciousness and it's going to C
circulate back around at some point and
I'm going to feel and think that same
way again so if I don't stop it see it
re-qualify it it's just going to keep
doing what it's doing and continue to
get energy from me right I'm feeding it
every time that it happens and I don't
take responsibility for it so as soon as
I feel contracted I need to take inter
responsibility and say why is why is my
state of being cont constricting right
now find a thought you know what what am
I needing to be aware of is find the
thought find the belief love it accept
it forgive it you're not wrong for
thinking this but I'm going to
re-qualify that with the energy I want
which is empowerment or whatever it
might be so they take it through the
Catalyst and to me that's where people
find the real answers of who who am I
really it's like you got you kind of
have to walk the walk to know who you
are because you can sit around all day
reading about who you are you know
meditating on who you are but until you
start showing up in your life
experiences as who you are the infinite
self the one who's never threatened the
one who has infinite love and patience
and for all you know be that self and as
you're practicing being that self you
actually start to feel like you're that
self so the self identification happens
through just the daily practice of being
that self rather than the egoic self
mhm yeah the catalysts are such
profound gifts yeah it's like and
sometimes they
um they
um they can show up in
very crazy ways um yeah like I I
remember
um
um there's there's a lot of um like kind
of like familial conditioning about um
you know in a way it's like
objectification of the child to be kind
of like a grandchild machine for for the
parent that wants you know that kind of
stuff and then there's there's almost
like a kind of like a phase of like okay
I'm I'm no longer going to argue about
it and I I'll just be peaceful about it
and then there's like a phase transition
from like equinity to okay well I'm not
going to be a doormat anymore MH yeah
and so then there's the just reflection
back of I'm not an object for you to
have grandchildren
[Laughter]
through you know and so sometimes it's
actually not equinity in a way equinity
can be another straight jacket mhm and
so that reflection back of there's no
one here and there's no one there
[__]
to your own parent yeah you know
something like that is uh whooo and that
is in a way it's so freeing and so
liberating to um unshackle what was kind
of holding one in like I can only be
this certain way with my parent or the
you know or
whatever um so the catalyst is
fascinating in in in that way um
and Okay cool so I want I wanted to ask
about that that's good that's good to
hear
um and it's also fascinating seeing like
in a way it's kind of like the Skittles
like all these different flavors tasting
of the rainbow like it's just like yeah
you know there there'll be an appearance
of whatever um if if one is you know
teaching a certain way there'll be a
resonance and there'll be wanting to be
with that and see if that's a path to
Freedom if there will be one that's
teaching a different way or if there
will be one that's saying there's
nothing to get like there's nothing to
get and and actually perhaps a little
bit
of will
actually oh you know it's already the
case it's already free you need a
teaching for every
step along the path right for wherever
somebody is there needs to be the right
pointing to get them to the next shift
and so there isn't just one perfect
pointing for everyone at all levels and
I think it takes a bit of that mirroring
awareness to like perceive where
someone's at and what they may be able
to what may land for them and what may
not land for them and um I see that a
lot in in non-duality meetings and stuff
where a lot of the people are there and
like just don't get the concepts and
they study them for years and it's like
I just honestly at the end of the day if
I had to be honest with you I still
don't really get it and it's like maybe
that's because you skipped an
intermediary stage which to me usually
is the heart usually people skip over
the heart and they want to go straight
to the concepts and stuff but it's like
you didn't really practice embodying
Universal love forgiveness for all
beings humility and gratitude service to
others the heart stuff that really like
ripens the soul and once you have that
really soft openhearted loving energy
those concepts of there's nothing to get
man you're like of course there isn't
cuz it's it's love and it's already here
it makes so much more sense to a Heart
full of love then someone who doesn't
have that contact or communication with
love at all times won't maybe be able to
grasp these amazing pointings that are
absolutely true but they can't really be
gotten as an idea it has to be a felt
experience of there's nothing to get and
then you can nod your head and you get
it you know m mhm yeah
yeah yeah I I I love how um you know for
for forgiveness and all kinds of healing
really has has been apparently
fundamental um you know um yeah there's
um yeah it's it's F it's it's
fascinating that you know
like um like feeling the the wholeness
that that that everything is obviously
and like that that that's that that's
what it is but and then being able to in
a way being able to say that it's always
been here and then also saying that
apparently there was a path that that
involved um opening up and um doing
things like um like repenting um yeah
and and it and it is it can be
challenging um to to to say that because
um because it's of course it's
challenging to say that repenting will
lead me to Freedom you know that's a
challenging thing to say but at the same
time if there really hasn't been
a um if there actually hasn't been like
a a um a
um uh saying that wow like holy [__]
that what happened like x amount of
years ago where where I did this and
like I'm willing to apologize for it and
and just to heal together about that
like it creates its own in a way its own
heart opening to that Universal love and
yeah that's the ACI path is to forgive
forgive your way to heaven sort of if
you forgive everything to a certain
extent then you finally see everything
shining as heaven everywhere and why
doesn't it already shine as Heaven
because you have all these judgments
about it you're dimming its light with
your projections and even the labels and
concepts are still dimming its light and
so that's the um the power of the
Innocence the course calls it innocence
but it's like the don't know mind of
course yeah also essential don't know
unknow yeah absolutely that's innocence
yeah yeah yeah and then that is what
enables the seeing in a way of paradise
and everything already yeah
even even the worst war is unconditional
love
Waring yeah it's Freedom Waring MH and
um
and and that's that's that's great um
the the don't know the unknow is like is
it I mean it's it's there in a baby it's
there in the the dog or the cat it's
there and like it's just blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah and absolutely what do you think
the dog hears when the humans
but it knows energy it knows the energy
you put out at it but it doesn't yeah it
doesn't mean much when you speak to it
right so it's like it's
always here and it's always
like yeah I heard a phrase recently that
someone said that I was like wow I love
that it said uh we're living we're
living in a museum of other people's
ideas like cup you know like someone
else chose the the word for this I
didn't name this cup I learned that it
was called cup desk chair Aon the
English language like I was taught all
these things I didn't make any of them
up myself so it's like everything is a
museum of past ideas from other people
and that's in the sense why we don't see
reality or we don't see the present
moment cuz it's plastered with labels
and ideas of what other people before us
thought and we've just like borrowed
their thoughts kind of a wild idea to
contemplate right I love that yeah
undeniably true though right the the
don't know the unknowing is what makes
in a way these these labels melt MH and
then there's the Perfection that every
the freedom that everything always is
and then and it's fine to use that word
cup it's just what's it's what's
appearing but it's great to in a way
undermine uh a box that has been so
strongly uh that it's kind of in a way
it's like like a name a name is a very
strong box um and so an
undermining
it and the freedom that can come from
the undermining um of that kind of that
contraction around that
label that that's a that's a good way to
to say it too yeah nice I love also the
the conversation about uh Freedom Waring
you mentioned um that's a hard one for
people to intellectually understand what
we mean when we say
there's no war in reality there's no
death in reality there's no abuse in
reality so these things are Illusions
you might call them and that would
really upset a lot of people to say that
because they're like how dare you say
all the Palestinians getting slaughtered
right now are just
Illusions so it's important for me to
like I always try to clarify what we
mean when we say that because we can
toss around these highly philosophical
statements and not really do justice
explaining them all the time and I think
sometimes things are better left unsaid
if they're not explained well so when we
say that what we're not saying is people
aren't experiencing all the terror
they're experiencing the pain and the
suffering and the death we're not saying
that they aren't experiencing that we're
saying that what is real and actual is
eternal and Incorruptible can't be
harmed it's forever and the basis of
true love and to love anyone has has to
begin with you perceiving that Eternal
element in them that is imperishable and
perfect and divine it's an extension of
Creator and it is to be valued as that
always so I'm not going to diminish you
down in my mind in my perception of you
to this delicate little body that's
getting blasted out of existence and
poor you you little victim to me that's
like an attack on that being because I
see a perfect Divine being in my
awareness and so although I will always
strive to protect every everyone from
harm that I can that's what love does at
the same time if someone dies in my
world I don't really experience it as
death because I never experience them as
a body I always experienc the Eternal
dimension of them like I do in myself so
when we say that war isn't happening in
reality we mean that Insanity under what
we could call sanity or natural law
there's no possibility of something like
War right cuz everything is one
everything is connected everything
exists in relationship there's only one
energy in the universe there's only one
mind one being in the universe so it
can't go to war with itself or against
itself that doesn't have meaning right
the war happens in the dream of
separateness when humans are under the
insane idea that we're separate from
each other and therefore you might be a
threat to me and this and that we form
tribes and then eventually we go to war
that's all uh like a person in a
straight jacket talking to thems you
know what I mean we would never tell an
insane person in a psych wward who's
talking to thems and terrified of the
Big Green hoblin Goblin chasing them we
would never say that they're not
experiencing that CU clearly the poor
soul is look at them running around the
hallway screaming by themselves you know
we understand they're deeply suffering
and so there's compassion and yet we are
awake in reality where we know there's
no Green Goblin chasing that person see
so that's what we mean when we say there
there's no war in reality humanity is
dreaming it together and co-creating it
together by violating every natural law
there is you know and that's why it
creates so much karma when we have
things like War child trafficking abuse
we just keep creating more karma for
ourselves so that's why to me I'm very
interested in looking at Humanity's
shadows and not just avoiding them
saying well I'm just going to meditate
and be spiritual by myself good luck
world that doesn't feel loving to me to
do that so I want to pay attention to
what's happening in the world so I can
bring my light and love and forgiveness
to it but I definitely don't want to fix
my attention on what's happening in the
world and get drawn into the negative
elements right I want to stay detached
in the sense of my identification with
the world you know as as something to be
feared or whatever I never fear what's
happening in the world but I also want
to know where the light needs to be sent
you know otherwise how can I really be
an Agent of Change on this planet um so
I think there's a parallel there between
when I really want to look at my Shadows
you know like I'm not afraid for
something to come up anymore uh in fact
I look forward to things manifesting so
I can heal and correct them in the same
way when I arrive at that disposition in
myself I will simultaneously arrive at
that disposition towards the world
because my world is me you know there
isn't a duality of inner World outer
world there's just one world and and so
what's happening outside of me also
feels like a part of me you know so I
take partial responsibility for it in
the sense of that needs healing and
light so all these different forms of
corruption we could talk about right
there does there does come a natural
sense of righteousness and Truth in you
that you're like we're not going to
stand for that anymore that's not loving
that's enslaving Humanity that's
contributing to suffering let's get rid
of that and let's build something
beautiful and true in its place um that
that has to come from a heart of love
right it can't come from an angry Heart
full of hatred and judgment towards the
Deep State and the Illuminati um you
can't really create positive change with
either fear or anger towards that energy
there has to be a forgiveness of it of
like look there's nobody really to blame
Humanity built this monster you know
this is a collective manifestation of
all of our greed and selfishness over
Millennia so why waste time being angry
at somebody let's just get down to the
work right and start healing
it
M
yeah yeah there's
a
like um something that is so free can
appear the way that it is appearing yeah
and that's the miracle and it's always
here and as long as there's like o only
only some only like the this me that is
separate and lacking wants to control
the appearance because it feels like
it's it's wrong and it's not wrong it's
that um it's actually perfect it's
perfect and then whatever is coming
through that is new to build just comes
through effortlessly to build and it's
it's not someone doing it anymore it's
just that there's been um so much um dis
solution of the center point mhm that
now is just a spontaneous building of
what's new yeah of the most beautiful
thing imaginable basic needs for
everyone people being free play Joy
abundance for all yeah yeah and it's
just
emerging you know it's just emerging out
of the metaphysics of what's happening
on the planet and Inc Consciousness you
know for thousands of years humanity is
like finally at that place where we've
kind of learned our lessons after
repeating them so many times and we're
like crying out for help from the
universe you know like help we're we're
not doing great down here we're in fact
kind of on the brink of annihilation uh
it took you know it sometimes it takes
that extreme to wake Consciousness up to
itself to say oh I've got to turn around
and go the other direction so whenever
it happens it's perfect because that's
what the universe wanted to experience
like as you know in the LA one through
our planet our planet is an experiment
the logos is is running and so maybe on
our experiment the logos turned up the
negative polarity dial a bit so that
we'd have a little more negative
polarity energy throughout our history
than other planets maybe do seems to be
what raw kind of alludes to right but
that's still an experiment of how will
the light overcome that challenge how
will the light overcome that difficulty
and it always does in the end so it's
always a good movie right with a great
ending but um there's that climax period
that we're in right now that can be
pretty uh you know you're gripping your
seat a little bit M mhm yeah
yeah it's fun right yeah oh my goodness
oh yeah yeah the the the Perfection that
it always has been and then the beauty
of the role that the body plays in
shepherding that new and that beautiful
the free abundant it's so it's so
exciting man and it's has always been
there when we're kids when we're kids is
it was always there like this these
basic needs being met and it's
like what does a kid do but wake up and
especially like in the summer or
whatever like it's kid's waking up and
it's like how do we want to play today
and like to have that be
where adults are at they're waking up
everything's metad all right so let's
let's do
um
because we'll we'll spend some we'll
spend some time on that um new Earth
architectures and communities and
whatnot we'll spend some time on that
give us give us the bit because I I'm
excited to also talk about actual like
the mechanism like the home Dow is the
mechanism that we designed to help make
that that transition and tokens actually
being backed by these basic needs
infrastructures so rather than being
backed by nothing so this
is so it's great that we have
everything's backed by nothing yeah
oh man I love it it's great I love a
good nonuel
gotcha everything's backed by nothing
yeah this is so good so someone in the
audience just like reached
[Laughter]
Satori so good man oh yes
oh yeah like we have um you know we have
an uh what what is an an evolution of
um of
currency um graphic on uh wow on the on
the homeow
website
and you can can you see that okay yeah
can you can see it cool bitcoin's
pumping today too by the way is it what
have you seen that it reached 38 wow
yeah whoa let's go new Earth let's go
new Earth baby yeah we spent some time
um designing this because um and this is
sort of what you what you're referencing
also in terms of understanding the Old
monetary systems because the old the old
monetary systems um uh and you just
talked about this on another pod that
you did just that you know instead of
having to um carry around all of the
stuff yeah he could carry around the
coin and then the coin can exchange
whatever you would like then it became a
paper paper bill yeah and then and then
now it's instead of having centralized
Banks and centralized governments now
there's a decentralized unit of exchange
Bitcoins cryptocurrencies but that's the
other things is that they're not backed
by anything right and home tokens yeah
go ahead go ahead on that note that
they're not backed by anything think
about how it's interesting we call it a
bill a dollar bill um what's a
bill um what is a bill a bill you have
to pay yeah it's it's a promise to pay
or a request to pay so that's they're
IUS right they're paper IUS they're debt
notes you might call them they don't
have any value they're a exchange a
negotiable instrument Y and so what are
we told to pay our debts with those IOU
bills which are supposed to have
equivalent amount of gold right so you
exchange the IOU and the the bank has to
say okay this is a bill for us we owe
this person uh $20 of gold because this
is a $20 bill I'm being billed for $20
of gold the bank is not you and so then
they give you $20 worth of gold so
you're giving them the bill that they
pay you and it's whoop the opposite
isn't it we pay with debt notes they
they charge us debt notes for everything
and really that's us if I give somebody
a bunch of debt notes they're supposed
to give me back gold in that value
because it's just an IOU a paper IOU and
so what happens you just pay a company a
bunch of dollar bills and then you get
nothing in return right so this is part
of the way that the finance Financial
system has been flipped upside down to
where we are actually the
creditors but and they're the debtors
like the government's the debtor even
according to like the 1933 Emergency
Banking Relief act where the United
States went bankrupt and they basically
asked all the citizens to return their
gold um was it Roosevelt I
believe Roosevelt requested everyone
turn in your gold we have to pay off
this debt we're bankrupt we're insolvent
right and that's when the dollar went
off the gold standard because the United
States went and solve it so now they're
like well don't worry like we'll just
keep printing these IOU bills and we'll
just use that to exchange and do
business and stuff and so now they have
this ability secretly by pretending they
they went and solve on purpose is what
I'm saying they went bankrupt on purpose
to the Fed so they could have a good
excuse to say give us your gold we're
going to take the gold the dollar off
the gold standard because now we can
just print as much as we want we have a
monopoly printing machine and we're all
playing Monopoly but I've got a money
printing machine and I'm just printing
out bills like crazy you know and buying
up properties with them and stuff so
that's the micro of our world in the
macro is that the banking system works
only for the elites you might call them
Financial Elites who where all the money
keeps getting siphoned to the 1% and
like you've probably seen this stat of
the uh was it 12 trillion printed over
the pandemic you know two to three years
um 90% of it wound up in the hands of
millionaires or
billionaires so that'd be like you know
10 and a half trillion dollars went to
the top 1% so it's like you see they're
it's the game that they're playing and
they just have to keep this illusion
going through propaganda and whatever
else that um you know you need to pay
your taxes and this is just the way it
is and life is getting harder and harder
the Dollar's getting inflated more and
more so our buying power is going down
it's like guys when are we going to all
stop and say let's all put your money
down okay we're being
cheated let's stop playing the game
where we're being cheated let's try to
reestablish Fair rules to the game
because we're all getting effed right
now and so that's what humanity is doing
through this kind of common law
movement okay so um I'll say the last
part of this and then you'll say the the
common law movement so the last part of
this is like this amazing emergence of
what is now um decentralization
technology yeah so now we have the we
have the ability to actually Peg tokens
instead of as like a shared
hallucination of of value yeah
um so now tokens being pegged with home
Dow to real world sustainable
regenerative assets of basic needs so
water wells food forests regenerative
homes regenerative Community areas wind
turbine solar panels free energy devices
self-sustaining self- sustaining
completely self- sustaining and with in
homesteading through the Dow the Dow is
this mechanism that if you Homestead
through it within just a period of some
years being a let's say what we call a
homie of the Dow homie of Home da Dow
you know you're basically developing it
yeah and as you do so whether you're
shepherding the food forest or whether
you're producing content or whether
you're actually building the communal
spaces of it or whatever you're actually
getting paid in home tokens that you're
then using to pay for the homestead
genius and so then within hopefully 5
seven years some along those lines if we
can get these we can get these 3D
printed homes like these beautiful 1,000
plus squ foot homes for $150 or so
thousand in in in the in Fiat but then
like within just some years you
completely all your energy is met your
food is met the water is met and the
hous they're all regenerative even free
energy at yeah baby let's go oh my gosh
let's go that's exciting let's go that's
the big one to me did you you see the um
the hilarious meme I I I uh shared to
the story it's Tesla Nica Tesla wearing
a make energy free again on his on his
hat dude yeah that's such a funny meme
and so that's this is this is the the
excitement about this mechanism and
what's um what's possible with you know
there's so many communities that are
part of our da ecosystem but obviously
the the da itself is the whole thing
it's everything the da is everything and
home da is
just
um uh uh it's basically osmosis of many
Dows in a way so you know the Comm the
communities that um there's ones that
are getting set up here in Austin that
are starting to work with us which are
wow yeah which are hundreds of acres of
land um or ones that are set up uh in
Europe or in southern uh Central and
South America um the United States all
these different places and it's like
dude the developers that come into the
Dow these homies they're already
developers of like megawatts of energy
of new regenerative energy or they
they're inventors that have already
built incredible sustainable
regenerative buildings or communities
and so this is all all like the internet
nobody and everybody owns it the
mechanism itself is supposed to obsolete
itself it's supposed to exhaust itself
it's made to make people be free of
their basic needs and then when that's
done and there's moneyless abundance
then the mechanism's Obsolete and it's
Freedom it's pure freedom and joy and so
I love that yeah go ahead and reply to
to that and include some of the the
common law um stuff and yeah let's let's
dance well I love that because so much
of this has to be about building
parallel systems and it's the reason I
love this is because it's a perfect
mirror to how you transcend your own ego
is exactly how Humanity has to transcend
our Collective ego which is like the
government structure we've built that
has this top- down control wants to
control everything it can get its hands
on that's our Collective ego we've built
to rule over us yeah Daddy government
mommy government I'll do whatever you
say even though all you do is betray me
and steal my money I'll still serve you
yeah please take all of this taxpayer
dollar and and fuel it into the military
industrial complex military industrial
complex child trafficking you name it
yeah you're paying for that stuff right
it's like why are you paying these
people still so in that conversation
right we have to acknowledge the problem
first that's self-awareness and that's
what um everyone who uses the term
conspiracy theorist is still on that
side of the awareness Spectrum where
they everyone who's choosing to just
acknowledge reality and be like all
right this sucks to ad
but child traffickers run the world it's
just a
fact the people who haven't seen that
yet or don't have the courage to accept
that yet that like all the most powerful
people in the world a huge majority of
them are like hardcore child traffickers
right that's a hard reality to accept I
certainly don't want that to be true I
wish it wasn't true but if I want to
heal Humanity I have to begin by
accepting that it is true right now so
how do we bring healing to that well
first we got to bring awareness to it so
there's movies like the sound of Freedom
that just came out that like broke all
these box office records with a tiny
little budget it shows that the
collective consciousness of humanity is
more more saying yes to acknowledging
these dark truths and looking at our
shadow but people who don't want to look
at the shadow will call all those people
conspiracy theorist so it's like you
know like gaslighting yourself or
something you you clearly have this
gigantic um narcissistic tendency and
every time you notice it your mind's
like come on you're not a narcissist
like that's crazy to think that you're
just confident you're like yeah yeah
that's right yeah and you like don't
want to look at that shadow and you've
given yourself an excuse not to so I see
this mirror happening everywhere right
of what happens within the individual's
evolution is exactly what happens at the
macro level but in like bigger ways so
it's harder to see like mainstream media
is another manifestation of the human
ego the part of us that tells us what we
want to believe and you know the
information that's convenient that's
controllable that's what our ego loves
to tell us
and that's what the mainstream media
does so there's all these parallels in
the systems we've built we've literally
built an external reflection of the
human ego in our government in our
monetary system in our food system in
our health care System we do to humanity
exactly what the individual ego does to
the individual and that's why I always
say law is 100% spiritual to me when I
talk about law we're really talking
about natural law all law is natural law
Eternal truth right it can't be violated
it can't be broken or changed and so
that's 100% spiritual but even beyond
that like law is non-physical we all we
all know that I can't be like hey Atlas
can you please hand me a law and put it
in my hand you're like here you go
here's us code
18273 and there it is no right it's
non-physical and what is non-physical is
spiritual we could call it right so law
is spiritual because it's all about
knowing who you are common law it it has
to begin with knowing who you are and
from there you understand what your
rights are so I am a child of the
Creator I am made by God and I am
endowed with the Free Will that God
itself has these kind of basic things
but because there's only God that means
everyone else is God too everyone else
is equal under God's eyes so all should
be treated equally and that's like basic
morality 101 that nobody any side would
disagree with even the um the uh
negatively polarized Elites of the world
let's say who are running the world
economic forum and have the worst plans
for Humanity even they would give lip
service to that right and be like
everyone's equal all should be treated
fairly the negative path will still say
that but if we don't recognize it we'll
we'll keep creating these systems that
enslave us because we're not really
aware of the equality of all beings like
and these are the basic needs you're
talking about that until we can meet
everyone's basic needs we should have no
other priority let alone be sending
hundred billion dollar to Ukraine and to
Israel for Foreign Wars like these
things should be upsetting to everyone
because it should be seen as this is
crazy we don't even have our basic needs
met and we're spending how much money to
kill people overseas love it yeah
exactly rant over so just like
um uh I want to give
the we
uh what we said earlier was if we got
the
alpacas yes I wanted to get the alpacas
well we'll
uh let's get the some co-hosts let's get
some co-hosts in here so let's uh get
that get that camera over there there it
is beauty yeah we got our beautiful
alaca joining
us yeah just that really that Natural
State just innocense and
just no
ideas I was thinking about that a minute
ago watching them when you watch any
animal you can do this thought
experiment but as we know through like
the density's model through the chakras
every chakra is a new level of spiritual
intelligence and so animals having only
the red and orange Ray chakras in
activation um that's the kind of like
Base Animal nature and like personal
nature and then we humans have the third
one naturally activated which makes us
the ego and the the personality we are
so it's like that's you without any
egoic structure
whatsoever that's what's left of you is
like that base animal nature to just be
and like get your basic needs met yeah
but you're not thinking about anything
exactly yeah yeah second density and
that's in
you that Stillness but you have to find
it yeah
and it's beautiful because it's always
already especially with the child it's
always already innocent there free
without that structure and then there's
all these conditioned ideas that are
just like picked up and it's like yeah
yeah I'm separate and I'm unworthy and I
have to prove myself and I have to earn
validation and oh oh I lack and I need
and and I know and look at all my ideas
and my Concepts and validate my Concepts
and ideas and
there's there's a there's there's all
kinds of dualities of right and wrong
and awake and asleep and all kinds of
things and so now um I have to attain uh
a big trophy and gold star which is
Enlightenment and then be validated for
that and um and so then that this this
becomes uh or attain material
possessions and jets and Yachts and
watches and and girls and houses and
whatever it is and by attaining those
things then and it's it's beautiful
actually hearing more and more I
mentioned this
um did do you ever watch Theo V this
past weekend I've seen Clips he just had
Tucker Carlson on I saw some of those
clips cool and there was a segment where
Theo was talking about how he how he
finally um he finally attained um uh the
like a couple years ago some of the
monetary success that he was seeking and
then what what hit him was like a like a
knife was just like dude that wasn't it
that wasn't what I projected out was
like I'm going to get this and then
that's going to be wholeness that's
going to be Freedom that's going to be
unconditional love and then it wasn't it
and that same pattern is happening all
over the place it's like I can't get
satisfied by the objects yeah or by
attainments or whatever it is I can't
get s Satisfied by it so I'm
insatiably going for more more more more
from a place of lack cuz the um you
could say like the expansion from from
wholeness is like you know new Earth
communities and whatnot and um but when
expansion's coming from that contracted
center point it's like I'm not going to
be whole until I get all of this stuff
to fill this insatiability um
and so yeah there's like this this
childlikeness that's pre preconditioned
unconditioned whatever you want to say
and it's in the dog it's in the cat too
it's just coming up for
like you know that licking or that that
meow you know and it's like that's it's
always been there like that's always
been there and absolute presence like
nothing outside of the present moment is
happening yeah mhm when you were talking
about the condition Bel
beliefs we were talking about parents
and their children a lot of parents do
this where they'll grow up really really
poor but they don't let their children
know that they're poor they try to never
talk about or complain about it in front
of their kids U my parents did that to a
certain extent we were pastors and so
they never were wealthy by any means
kind of like lower middle class
teetering on the lower
class paying rent just getting by so
there's a lot of financial stress and
stuff but they said that they always
tried their best to make it not apparent
to us even like Christmases where they
could only get us like one gift you know
they made it a childlike thing of like
you're G to get one big gift this year
and that is it's beautiful that parents
do that obviously but what they're
basically saying is like let's not
transfer our nightmare to our children
you know let's not transfer that nasty
label that we're stuck with poor lacking
to our child cuz they recognize the
innate innocence of the child that does
have a concept of lacking Basics a child
doesn't even know what that means
initially right basic needs are already
seen as being abundant and omnipresent
so the child doesn't have that stress in
its mind and it's just living more
childlike so the Aging is really just
like concept collecting or conditioning
piling up and we call it aging but
really what we are doesn't age it is
that innocence we just have to strip off
the layers of the concepts we've piled
on top of it I love a concept collection
yeah with what doesn't
age what a
paradox and so the ashtavakra says so
many famous Eastern texts say things
like the master is a child or as Jesus
said you must become like a child if you
want to enter the Kingdom right that's
what it's pointing
tohm
y hell yes hell yes okay so gosh and I
mean then that's also circles us to the
start of the pond too where that's just
there's just that's just it like
whatever like just that whatever and it
was this is your
life you know
um yeah like like waking up and just
playing with those basic needs being met
whatever it is and so okay so
now um you know you were you were you
were sharing with us a bit about um the
what do what do you use as like the the
label or the terminology some say like
Matrix control system or whatever yeah
um um what what do you use as sort of
like the label we we use as a label for
the we call it new Earth or like these
basic needs architectures
infrastructures like we we call it that
like in terms of those new Earth
communities what do you usually use when
you say the old stuff some people call
it the Matrix or Matrix control system
what do you usually old Earth what do
you what do you usually use as a as a
word for what you've been sharing
Collective ego is what feels most
accurate for me but I don't use that a
lot because I know that that doesn't
mean to others to most people what it
means to me so the Matrix is a
convenient label for that because we all
have that movie in mind of what a matrix
is it it appears to be real but it's all
fake we get that and the Matrix is a
nice easy summary of that um but really
The Matrix is all the shared
hallucinations that you talked about and
really just like I've actually had this
thought recently that Humanity would
probably have reached Collective
Enlightenment you know thousands of
years ago if we lived long enough to
remember the past but because we have
such short lifespans you know less than
100 years which is like super short we
don't even remember by the by the time a
new communist takeover attempt happens
or a new war breaks out or a new crisis
or pandemic breaks out nobody alive
remembers the past one they weren't
alive for it you know so it's a new
stimulus to them and they get they get
sucked into the propaganda all over
again just like their grandparents did
in their generation it's because like if
we lived to be probably even 200 we
would all have been alive through many
cycles of proxy wars and uh communist
takeover attempts we've seen it all
happen already and that's why we see
this the younger generation is again
getting duped into the propaganda
because they don't actually know what it
is communism Marxism and what it leads
to they're told an idealistic version of
it and that's what has happened to every
generation before them where that you
know whether in Russia or Germany where
these things happen so mankind just
keeps repeating the same mistakes is
what I'm getting at partially because we
just don't live very long so we don't
gain the wisdom that we probably need to
gain and even in the law of one raw
actually says right that that's why they
came to the Egyptians 11,000 years ago
because they were only living to like 33
years old and so raw's social memory
complex you know seeing this happening
on Earth was like oh my gosh that's a
big problem we got to go help these
people so it is like it is seen as I
think I think they say third density was
intended to be a Thousand-Year lifespan
and you know in the Bible there's like
old few old passages that allude to um
their ancient ancestors whoever wrote
the Bible's ancestors Methuselah and
stuff who lived to be like 700 900 and I
never really took that seriously as a
kid but now that I'm older I'm like I
absolutely think you know whether 10,000
years ago 20,000 years ago people were
living that long but Ross says because
tribalism separation Consciousness took
more of a foothold on the planet and we
started separating into tribes and
groups and then countries and then go to
war tons of killing tons of death it
just lowered the planet's frequency so
much that Earth is only able to host a
very short lifespan now or perhaps the
Earth's intelligence chooses to lower
the lifespan as an act of Mercy on the
collective who is doing such insane
things to each other that it's like
let's make this nightmare of a lifetime
a little bit shorter for these poor
beings because they're in a nightmare
they're in hell right now and so that's
why reaching Heaven is to raise the
frequency of the planet back into Unity
the awareness of our Oneness where I
think once we reach that more on a
collective level we'll start seeing
humans living 200 300 500 years you know
in the future and that'll be the normal
lifespan I think it's a reflection of
our you know our Collective
frequency yeah what you're what you're
saying there the word that you you use
is like a collective ego when you were
saying that there was a there was a good
way for that came up here to say it as
like sort of that like the illus
illusion of a center point and like when
um when there is that then it's like um
you'll have the this like the Sackler
thing happen um you'll have Purdue Fara
happen basically you'll have an opioid
epidemic happen yeah yeah um so yeah
like that's like the pattern that
manifests or like whatever those kind of
like those influencers are that all they
do is talk about material possessions
and um getting more followers and
getting more objects and getting more um
sexual objects and whatnot like that's
sort of like the or the whatever those
major uh companies are like uh Black
Rock and whatnot those major firms that
have so much assets under management and
whatnot like that's sort of like the in
a way also like a a a a manifestation of
of like like sh shareholders that just
can't get can't fill can't fill what
seems to be
missing um or even on a on a micro level
it's like in the conversation it becomes
about wanting to be validated it becomes
about like here's here's here's what my
my my story or my experiences and you
know and um you know Listen to listen to
it and that I'll validate it I'll
validate yours and then you know we both
have a strengthened ego and go on our
way yeah it's just like it is like a bit
of a jerk off session in a in a way a
jerk off
session yeah I mean so I like that
you're talking about the chasing
outcomes and desires because to me
that's one of the pillars of what ego is
I like to call it the three beliefs of
ego first belief is lack so that feeling
you have that you're fundamentally
incomplete in some way that you need you
need to fulfill yourself somehow that's
that is what the ego is right it is the
belief and
lack but then secondly the the next
belief is an extension of the belief and
lack which is the that that urge you
feel to chase pleasure in the world all
the things you mentioned right sex drugs
rock and roll there's this this
compulsion in me to go chase something
outside myself and when I get it I
really believe it's going to make me
happy that is also what the ego is right
and so those are like two different
beliefs they're kind of the same belief
but for me it's helpful to split them
under one and two and then comes the
third and final belief which is the
extension of that urge to go fulfill
myself in the world with pleasure is the
belief in control or like personal
doership that I actually can act
separately from life and manipulate life
into my favor how I want it to be I'm
something separate right so I act apart
from life I'm an indiv idual actor
that's the third belief and I can't find
anything outside of those three
beliefs that the ego is or does you know
like everything it does falls into one
of those three camps it's lack
attachment or control and those three
whips are running us all the time and
then what a manifestation of that in our
society it's all about lack everyone's
dirt poor money is hard to come by we
create this scarcity culture and then
everyone wants you know the sex symbols
the the shiny objects the luxurious
things everybody thinks that's what's
going to fulfill them so everybody is
working for those things and then the
belief that we are apart from one
another or apart from Life yeah drives
the rest of the actions to make us hate
each other judge each other separate
into tribes and stuff it's all our
attempt to control everything right
right isn't isn't it isn't that nuts um
that the um PE like people of a same
land um that have been on the land for
so long right and then somehow there's
like whatever that ucer border that is
drawn and then these people of the same
land like of the same
culture same food and music and stuff
like that all of a sudden they have
another label slapped on top of them
which is the nationality that is now
separate mhm and then because of that
separate nationality then
there's [__] you you're lesser y and so
it's kind of crazy that like that
there's all these um like manifestations
of that Center pointedness and you know
and uh that um even even the ideas of of
like of lacking or um or uh attachment
or control even those things come from
in a way that there is an entity there
is a center point there is or like the
last one there is a controller or a doer
there's someone inside that is able
to that it's not the sky that it's not
already the
windh yeah and there's something solid
there that that's not the sky or not the
wind right there's a boundary
somewhere yeah well when we talked about
the alpacas a minute ago like that's
what you're saying is so true like the
ego the ego can't be the ego if you
subtract any one of those three
ingredients it's no longer what we
consider ego anymore so for example you
have lack and you definitely have
attachments you know desires to go get
something in the world sex pleasure
money but you have no belief or thought
that you're an individual actor to who
can go do those things then you're still
just like an alpaca chewing the grass
meeting its basic needs but full of this
pent up desire for things that you can't
go chase after so like that's definitely
not the ego either the ego is absolutely
the part of us that does and wants to go
chase after things so it's there they're
a foundation right like each one rests
upon the previous and I think they also
are root chakra sacral chakra solar
plexus chakra because even the beliefs
themselves kind of show the
representatives of those energy centers
the root is the animal nature right
basic Primal survival so lack is that
driver for Primal survival the reason
that the animal is always hunting for
food and wants to reproduce is because
it has this urge inside of it self that
it needs to get something or do
something CU it's lacking something so
it's like not bad right it's what makes
Mother Nature run only in the animal
that's innocent because it's not
self-aware of its lack yet so it's like
there's lack but that's not a problem
because I just go meet my needs type of
thing but then as you progress up the
energy centers at the orange Ray you
become more of the personal self there's
a distinction between myself and my
environment that happens just briefly
maybe even the word um it's like a more
like a natural whatever response or
spont anous thing which is like the body
goes to get water or the body goes to
get food it's like cuz it's almost like
we're kind of adding a label of like
lack and needing to fill it but it's
there's no concept it's a it's like a
natural body function it's a function of
a body totally
water food instinctual it's yeah like
the body needs water and the the
intelligence of the body knows it needs
water but there isn't like a feeling of
lack in the animal because it can't
self-reflect like that
to make an idea out of lack so for the
the body's intelligence like it knows
it's one with the environment so I just
have to walk over there and drink the
water it's not lacking in any way I'm
just in relationship to different things
at different times you know so but as we
go up the chakras then we get to the
solar plexus the yellow Ray and that's
where ego finally comes online when
there's selfawareness or self-
referencing I like to say where you can
think about yourself as an individual
object in your environment and then past
and future
and then economies monetary systems
everything else we see that manifests in
third density it's quite a leap for
Consciousness you know like
Consciousness makes these huge leaps at
every density level but nevertheless
we're on that precipice of going forth
density now and so we can look back at
third density and all of its amazingness
and still say but there's a whole lot of
problems to clean up at this level still
you know the corruption and stuff so
third density Consciousness will serve
Us in the fourth density once it's
purified
but that's what we're doing now right
yeah I love that um that selfawareness
or self consciousness or um or knowing
as a as a individual object is another
something that doesn't have bounds or
that doesn't have objects or that is
nothing everything to then say that no
this
is knowing it's knowing like even even
before all that other stuff knowing
knowing that this is something knowing
that this is something that this is
entity that this is separate that this
is name that this is time and space with
others and ideas knowing knowing all of
that like whereas wind like the simple
like
these tree
leaves you know like there's no knowing
not even a little bit of
knowing yeah there just spontaneous
arising yeah it's so
beautiful you want people to see it so
bad and even like even like saying like
like like wanting to see like it's like
it it is already the wind and it's like
there's no one that could hear it and
there's no one that's saying it and like
that's the freedom and the beauty that
it
is and so like even that thing of like
wanting okay well now I know what it is
and now I know what it is and now I will
impart this knowing onto those that
don't know that's a whole beautiful
trap
and it's still what's appearing um it's
still beautiful but um beautiful trap
appearing
really yes yes it's a it's a such a
precious gem
really yeah um and then this yeah I just
I love all the ma all the manifestations
of that are uh are so um beautiful with
all the different like robes and um all
of the different uh fancy silly hats and
uh all the different accolades and
titles holier than thou yeah um please
kiss my feet
mhm big trap watch out
danger and it's like there's a baby the
baby isn't none of that mhm none of that
baby doesn't know who to bow to who's to
kiss oh just like like just grabing
other child and it's like let's play
let's go play outside let's you know um
whatever whatever with games and balls
and whatever is happening I love it yeah
yeah um okay so let's see um how about
um let's let's let's wrap up on how um
we you you know I I like how you said
that it's like the that Collective ego
which you also saw in the videos as like
separation porn is one way that I also
described what was uh happening
apparently
and and so now um there's a a a
transition into this new Earth basic
needs being met that kind of thing so um
how so how what what what are you what
are you like excited about or honed in
on or how are you sharing that
transition well yeah this will be a long
wrap-up then um so I'll I'll do my best
to summarize this this is one of those
topics that like is truly profoundly
life-altering
and I'm like careful about who I drop it
on because um it needs to be given due
Justice you know like if it's explained
so um I'll preface that as I say this
that like this conversation is in the
very best way um so Paradigm shifting
that like you'll probably remember
watching this podcast right now as you
hear me talk about it and that's this
concept of the legal fiction we
mentioned the straw man which gets to
the heart of this Collective ego
idea and the very short Abridged summary
is that when you're born the United
States government essentially creates a
corporation out of your name it's uh
like a business Trust essentially and
let's break this down as we go a little
bit so when that when that there's that
um the body that that is apparently born
that there's that um label right away
which is this is the this is the name
this is the date of birth this is what
it is this is what it is um this is the
social security number registered to it
the birth certificate gets a qip number
and then later you get your Social which
has its own number and the so your
social well I'll get you that in a
second um um so they make a corporation
out of your name and if you think about
the atmology of Corporation it's very
interesting um Corp oration so Corp is
obviously from Corpse Corpus body I
believe in Latin yeah which is like body
or dead the dead corpse oration
means or speaking yes so Corporation the
word literally means the dead speaking
or dead speak and so that's why they
call things like Facebook McDonald's
King corporations because they are dead
entities also sometimes called
artificial an artificial person that's a
corporation and that's because it
doesn't exist right it's a total
illusion um I always use this example of
when Facebook got called into court for
colluding with the government to censor
election stuff Trump and Biden and they
had to report to the federal or Supreme
Court did we see a Facebook logo bounce
into court and sit in front of the mic
and I am Facebook The Entity known as
Facebook it's such a funny who who
showed up Facebook logo B think about it
into the scene how can Facebook appear
in court there is no
Facebook so Mark Zuckerberg shows up hi
I'm here to represent Facebook yeah so
I'm I'm the representative I'm the
acting agent of this Corporation because
it doesn't exist so a corporation is
kind of like a legal Veil or Shield that
a person a living person can like wear
for like legal protection or you know
like all the stuff that Facebook does
legally that broke all these federal
laws someone's going to have to pay so
instead of throwing somebody in jail
like all of the employees the everyone
can deflect blame on someone else and be
like I was just doing what I was told my
boss told me to do that my boss told me
to censor that person so it's the boss's
fault the boss said well they told me to
do it and at the end of the the day it's
like all right Facebook is just a
corrupt
corporation everyone's in on the
corruption so let's just make them pay
us a lot of money so they just charge
the company Facebook couple billion or
whatever and then the lawsuits settled
and they move on but like what should
really happen under the law is that like
everybody should go to jail for that
crime because it was people that did
that people tried to steal the election
right not a company called Facebook so
we're already like two steps removed
from reality in the world we live in
because everything has been made into a
corporation mhm and
including you so including the bodies
themselves including the bodies
themselves so you said that the the
corporation um is kind of like a that B
it's a Bound in a way it's a a defense a
shield and then then it can also be used
at that at that level of a of a m a
multinational um cor Corporation and
then there's a nation itself being a
corporation y so there's kind of like
the United States yes is a corporation
so your corporation is your all caps
name anywhere you see your name in all
capital letters that's how corporations
are listed in the law the all caps name
is on your birth certificate your Social
Security your driver's license any bill
you get charged is always your all Cap's
name like in the mail and then when you
get uh when you want to apply for a loan
or a credit card or anything Financial
they always ask for your
what um your Social Security yes yeah
they always need your social security
why well because your penis girth your
penis girth for skin what do they ask
you for they what they do is they make a
Trust bank account it's called your
treasury direct account some people also
call it the cqv trust and it's basically
them backing the Dollar by human labor
so it literally is like the Matrix the
world we live in and that when Neil W
wakes up in the Matrix he's inside of
this EG shell thing on the side of a
giant machine that's harvesting his
energy as a battery and he looks and he
just sees batteries plugged into
machines everywhere and every human is
being siphoned for their life force
energy that's actually what is happening
in the sense that the when the 1933
Emergency Banking Relief act happened
they passed hjr 192 which is H the house
joint resolution 192 and that's where
they said hey we're insolvent so we have
to give up all our assets to our um who
we're in debt to which was the Federal
Reserve so that's why they said hey all
you citizens give us your gold because
it's really our gold because you're our
corporate entity you're our employees
basically so give us your gold we'll
give it to the feds to pay off some of
our debt and then what we'll do is we'll
just have these debt notes go in
circulation that aren't backed by gold
anymore and so if they took the dollar
off the gold standard in
1933 then the question is what did they
back the dollar by cuz it has to be
backed by something and what they backed
it by was human labor in that every
person who's born gets a dollar value
estimation I believe now it's $5 million
is where your account starts at because
they basically said and this is very
intelligent of these kind of mustache
twirling villains who did this is that
they realized what's more valuable than
gold what's more valuable than silver
well obviously a person is way more
valuable than gold right because a
person person can start businesses work
jobs have loans take out loans do
business deals create products a person
is like unlimited potential for the
economy right and you could even be an
Elon Musk for all they know so just like
by virtue of existing every human being
is given an inherent value of $5 million
by the fed and then from there forward
every job you work every loan you take
out every credit card you swipe
everything you do adds to your account
balance because your it's backed by your
labor and your labor is infinite right
you can work and do as much as you want
to do so every time that you write a
signature your signature is what prints
money or allows them the ability to
print more money because if you want to
buy something you have this because the
dollar is backed on your credit now you
have basically unlimited money in your
TDA and So when you buy that $5,000
thing they have to add5 ,000 to your
account so the problem is they never
told you about your account and they
never told you that they backed the
Dollar by your human labor and by
everybody's human labor why because they
want to keep it all to themselves so
what they do is these accounts grow to
hundreds of millions of dollars or
billions by the time you're our age and
they trade them on the bond market they
bond them securitize them and trade them
so like your Social Security account
your birth certificate is also a
financial instrument with a qip number
on it they bond all those things
together and trade them on the on the
bond market like stocks so like you're
like a stock to them in that when you
start making money all the money that
goes into your bank account has to be
reported to the Fed so they know exactly
how much money you're making unless you
have crypto or something and so they're
always adding to your account balance
and they print the equivalent amount of
debt notes so that 36 33 trillion dollar
of debt America is in those are actually
the unclaimed Securities of its
citizens that the United States needs to
pay them back for so their debt in other
words United States debt is not really
to the Federal Reserve it's to the
people whose labor they're
collateralizing so to paint that picture
we have this Collective ego in the sense
that we're all identified with a false
self the all caps name and we keep
signing documents claiming to be the all
Cap's name when really we're not that
corporate entity the allc Caps Aaron
Scott ABY that's a company that the
United uned States Corporation made at
my birth I am the living man and I can
call myself whatever I want you know I
can change my name every day if I want
so you have to make a distinction in the
law of who you are in comparison to the
artificial person and so you do that
through affidavits and certain documents
where you swear under penalty of perjury
like I know who I am I am the living man
Aaron of Aaron Scott of the House of
abke is what I say um and I am the I am
now the acting agent of the all caps
name basically I'm power of attorney I'm
the agent and the reason that's powerful
is because this is where all the power
falls back into our hands in the legal
Matrix we're all trapped in is that we
are living and alive and can do things
and corporations are dead and do not
exist and can't do anything so there's
something in the law called an an
unrebutted affidavit where the way that
if two people are in a conflict in law
you're supposed to RIT a document where
you claim everything that you swear
under penalty of perjury is true and
correct this is what happened this is
what I saw this is what I did I swear on
the Bible that's true and then you sign
it you get it notorized now that's a
legal document of truth that you can
submit in court of law and so you
present me your affidavit and then if I
disagree I have to write my own
affidavit and sign it and swear under
penalty of perjury so we have to do the
honorable thing and swear on the Bible
which is what law is based on and that's
considered Honorable in in law and so if
you say I am the principal of this
account I am the acting agent of this
all Cap's name and I'm the living man
not the all Cap's name I swear this is
true under penalty of perjury what
corporations going to write their own
affidavit to rebut
yours right nobody because Mr Facebook
can't write an affidavit if Facebook
wants to write an affidavit somebody who
works there has to write one claiming to
represent Facebook and put their ass on
the line so this is the way that people
are discharging debts now is that um on
the money conversation this is where the
parallel between abundance infinite
abundance and lack is is that you have
never this goes for everybody listening
but I'm going to say it to you you have
never borrowed money from anybody in
your life you've always borrowed your
own money yeah yeah yeah exactly you've
always borrowed your own money
and they've loaned you your money from
your TDA account that you don't know
exists that's worth hundreds of millions
they just give you the loan because
that's why they need your social that's
the checking account number of your
account um to then loan you your own
money so they don't put up any of their
own collateral like Banks never loan
anyone a cent of their own money they
they tap into your TDA account and they
loan it to you and then they tell you
you need to pay them back the TDA
acronym stands for again treas y direct
account so at the United States Treasury
your Social Security account is really a
TDA account that's worth way more than
they say you're going to get when you
retire and you said it starts at five
million I think it starts at about five
million that's what I've heard from
people who like used to work at the SSA
or the IRS but it's it's held at the
treasury and so they tap into your
treasury direct account and they take
whatever money you you're getting the
loan for loan it to you and then say now
pay us back with interest so it's like
they're triple robbing you or triple
dipping you they didn't put up anything
of their own right a loan is supposed to
be this is my money I will loan to you
and trust you with so there's no equal
consideration the bank puts up nothing
the credit card company puts up nothing
they risk nothing and then they make you
pay them back your own money with
interest so you're the slave and they're
the the master in that relationship so
what people are doing now is saying it's
called a conditional acceptance this is
one of the many ways to discharge debt
and this is essentially the method I
used to discharge my Camaro I used a
different discharge method for my other
car but you you send a letter to the
bank or to the uh in my case the car
loan company Bank of America and you
return them their written presentment
and you say I conditionally accept this
bill like I'll pay this if you can just
validate the debt for me and validation
of debt is required under UCC law
consumer law um if someone says you owe
them a debt they have to be to prove
that to you nobody can just say you owe
them a debt and not prove it so when
you're conditionally accepting you're
not in conflict and judges need
conflicts to drag people into court if
there's no conflict they can't pull you
into court so you're like Hey brother
thank you for this bill I really
appreciate it I would love to pay this
bill actually um I just need you to
validate the debt for me and then we're
good and I'll pay it and you're putting
the ball back in their court and guess
what everything that they're doing on
their end is fraud and so they can't
prove the debt they can't validate the
debt cuz they never did give you any of
their own money they can't show you the
bookkeeping where they lost
$20,000 and deposited it into your
account because it never happened they
loaned you your money right so this is
another reason why when bills come in
the mail uh you get a credit card bill
let's say it's always written in a
positive balance not a negative balance
but they're telling you it's a debt but
debts are supposed to be written in a
negative balance that's basic accounting
credits are positive debts are negative
they say you owe us $5,000 and here's a
bill for $5,000 and it doesn't have a
negative sign in front of it that's
because they're extending you your own
credit but they write on the bill this
is a this is a debt so that's a lie it's
a total lie but they write it and so if
you believe the lie another parallel if
you believe the lie then you will pay
them money for something you don't owe
so the way to get remedy under the law
is to basically put the truth trth to
into action on your behalf and say yeah
yeah I'll pay this bill just prove to me
that you actually gave me that 5,000 of
yourself and they can't and then you do
something called the administrative
process which is like a three to four
letter sequence where you just give them
like two to three opportunities to give
you remedy you say hey give me 30 days I
I need in 30 days prove to me I owe you
a debt and then I'll pay it and they
they'll play dumb with you they'll say
we don't we don't know what you're
talking about pay the bill or you're
going to get a late fee they'll ignore
you or whatever and then you send
another letter that says like notice of
liability hey you you um defaulted on
our agreement to validate the debt I'm
going to give you one more opportunity
to cure you have another 15 days to
validate this debt and then they don't
and they default again and then you
issue them uh notice of uh
dishonor which says hey you've defaulted
twice in our agreement I'm the one who's
being truthful and honest here and
you're not so I'm going to take you to
court and you go to to the court with
all your document proof you send
everything certified mail so you have a
certified copy that they received your
document on this date so they can't say
we never got those letters right so you
hold them to nothing but the truth and
you let the truth fight your battles and
because under UCC law they have to be
able to show the bookkeeping where they
did put up equal consideration and they
can't and they never will then the judge
says case dismissed and discharges the
debt and sometimes if you can if you
want to go after them for violating laws
you can get like5 to $10,000 per
violation because it's part of UCC law
and USC Law that if any of these codes
are broken it's a $110,000 penalty or
$5,000 penalty so some people are going
after it that way I don't like the
fighting approach too much I just like
the coming in honor coming in peace just
to find out what's true and what's true
is it's all fraud right so this is the
movement I'm talking about where people
are waking up to the fact that can you
can walk the example through of How It's
like discharging like a debt on a car or
something like you were saying so what
what is that then like cuz you one has
to take out a loan let's say for a for a
purchase of a car or maybe if you're not
able to just drop all the cash money on
it or whatever okay so but but then
what's the what's happening there yeah
so so the guy so I bought my Camaro from
a a cop a young guy in Dallas when I
lived in Denver and I drove down here to
meet him and um I had the loan taken out
from the bank it was like 50k uh for the
car and so I gave him the check from the
bank that they loaned
me so he went and deposited in his bank
account and had a great time with it but
I turned around and sent the bank a
letter when after they sent me my first
bill to say Hey you know your first
payment's due you owe us you know 650
bucks I just basically said hey I would
be happy to to pay this um just validate
that this is in fact a debt and then
they play hassle with you for about 3 to
6 months for me it was like 6 months I
just keep returning all their
presentments with a conditional
acceptance I'll be happy to pay this if
you can validate the debt UCC one- I
can't remember the law and you're always
citing the law for them so they can see
I'm acting lawfully here and that also
looks really good in court when one
person's sticking to laws you can never
be um you can never be judged for having
a wrong understanding of the law so even
if you try to cite a law and you're like
this law says you can't do that and you
go to court and the judge says well you
kind of misinterpreted that law there
they can do that you can never be
punished for that right you'll never be
punished for trying to abide by the law
you just may not win the case but they
won't punish you for it so that's why
it's honorable always to use the law
which is like a metaphysical
representation of natural law right I
want to live in perfect obedience to the
truth that's all we do to get remedy
which which is so cool like what a
perfect parallel to the um the Journey
of transcendence right we transcend the
false nature our false identifications
through sticking to the truth I am not
this body I'm not this person I am the
Eternal self and we have to continue
identifying with that self until
eventually it becomes our experience and
it's no different in this journey when
people wake up to this it's this
terrifying realization oh no they made a
corporation out of my name and it's like
a corporate slave that they own and it
can be scary for people to wake up to
this but I say yeah that's all true but
you have nothing to fear because now
that you're awake to who you are now you
have all the power you just have to
learn how to use your power which means
learn the law and learn how to use the
law but people are doing it by the
thousands now and I'm actually so you do
that with the Camaro for a couple times
and then what happens after those six
months then eventually um the you can go
either arbitration it's called where
it's all done through the mail like the
court proceedings are done through the
mail I worked with a guy named Brad
Tipton who helps people discharged
basically for a living and so he says
after you've sent them six presentments
or more uh endorsing their presentment
with a conditional acceptance if they're
still sending you them because the bank
will just do that forever like they
don't they don't lose anything by always
sending you bills in the mail but you
have to return it under the law like if
you don't return it with the correct
response like silence is acquiescence in
the legal world if somebody sends you a
bill and you don't respond and say
either yeah here's the money or no I
don't owe you money then that they can
take you to court and be like pay up and
the judge will make you pay up because
you didn't you acquiesced right so you
have to respond to all their
presentments otherwise they can get you
that way but after about 6 he contacts
the court and I I don't know exactly
what he does but he basically shows all
the documents the green return receipts
and then the judge just closes the case
with the bank bank so then it shows up
like on my credit score it just shows up
as account charged off so I didn't have
to pay the rest of the balance and then
they stop sending me stuff in the mail
so it's called
discharging interesting so there's like
a a card that is that is wanted and then
there's a a loan that the bank gives for
it and then the you you give that amount
of money to the person for the title and
the car they go deposit it and then you
go through this sequence and then you're
discharged of owing a a debt of 50 Grand
or what because I I don't actually owe a
debt that's the truth when you said like
the bank gives you the loan that'd be
the one correction is they actually
didn't give me a loan like the bank
didn't loan me anything they tapped into
my hidden bank account that I was never
told about the T the TDA the treasury
direct account and they loaned me my own
money they gave 50 from your own like
TDA yep from your SSN TDA that's why
they need my social security number like
even under SSA law it says no one can
ask you for your social it says that and
nobody can can punish you for not giving
your social so like a credit card
company or something they're not allowed
under law by the law to refuse to open
your account if you don't give them your
social but they do right if you don't
give a credit card company your social
they will not open a credit line for you
and they they'll keep asking you for
your social why because they don't want
to give you their own collateral they
want to cyer in your collateral and loan
it to you so they can triple dip you
right so that's why we see the balance
of power the way it is where
corporations have like unfathomable
amounts of money and the individuals the
people are more and more getting more
and more poor as time goes on because
there's this wealth transfer happening
where it's like a giant you know thing
that's siphoning all the money and the
life force energy from the people and
we're like playing into the system we're
still paying our taxes we're still
taking out loans paying high interest
rates when they're collateralizing our
labor mhm and and making money off of it
without us knowing it so it's absolutely
in every sense of the word
enslavement but it's like the 14th
amendment that was supposed to have
ended um like African-American slavery
it didn't actually end slavery it just
made slavery commercial because the 14th
Amendment is what gave the government
the right to create a artificial person
out of your name the legal fiction the
strong the all caps name the 14th
Amendment is the power that granted them
the right to do that and what's really
interesting um I wish I could almost
screenshot this to you there's a tweet
from Trump back in like I want to say
2018 you won't find it on the internet
but I have it screenshot saved where I
don't know if you remember this but
there was a certain time when like you
know the mainstream Media news outlets
were trying to mock Trump for like not
knowing the Constitution and that was
one of the things like like headlines
they were running with was like
President Trump forgets Constitution and
embarrassing kurlu at the White House
things like that right and they were
trying to pin that on him and he
actually does know the Constitution
really well and so he tweeted back um
something like this I almost have it
memorized so he says all you people
trying to mock me for not knowing the
Constitution do you know what the 14th
Amendment did he said the 14th Amendment
turned you all into legal
fictions and he said by voting for me or
anyone you committed a treason against
your Republic form of
government because when the United
States went insolvent in
1933 the the go the republic government
collapsed and they made a corporation
called the all caps United States that's
why you always see the United States in
all capital letters because they're also
a corporation so like a private
for-profit business like McDonald's
regulated by done in Brad street like a
business pretending to be a government
so it's like a business model to pretend
to be the government and trick people
into believing it like it's it's really
no different than how a lot of companies
trick their customers into thinking that
their product's really great when really
we find out five years later it's really
shitty Pro uh product but for five years
they T we have the best product and
everyone should buy it and everyone
believed it and bought it but all along
it was trash like that's kind of what
the government is is that they're
pretending to be a government but
they're actually a business doing
business as United States all capitals
so that's another part of the Matrix
right is now this business is hijacking
the country and the business is run by
Bankers of course because the United
States went insolvent to the banks so
the it's they're the debtors of the bank
so the banks are really running the
government making the decisions through
these corporate veils so the way you
find freedom is to transcend your
fictional entity your corporation the
all Cap's name via some kind of sworn
document that you send to the president
you send it to the Secretary of State
you notify everybody who you are this is
one of the simple processes for status
correction and then you have a public
record that you keep a copy of and you
have the green return receipt for it you
have a public record that could be used
in court where you say hey I already
notified everybody that I'm not that all
Cap's name here's my documents right
president got it Secretary of State got
it uh the treasury got it IRS got it and
it's it's very very simple in that sense
but where people fail in common law is
that they they haven't really grasped
the idea yet that they truly are a
sovereign being that nobody has the
right to tell you what you can or can't
do the natural law is just the law of Do
no harm right as long as you're not
harming anyone you have the free will to
do whatever you want and nobody can tell
you otherwise that's the the law of the
land that Humanity let's say the United
States was initially set up on th but
again that's a law form that does not
help governments gain power it keeps
governments from Gaining power so all
that's happened is the human ego has
learned how to gain the system over the
few hundred years you know of our our
country's history and each generation
just takes a little more power right it
just evolves very gradually over time so
there's nobody to blame once again for
this super corrupt system where they
they weaponize us with fake money and
they make fake corporations out of our
name they don't tell us about and that's
that's how they can throw us in jail and
find us for traffic tickets is we keep
swearing to be the all Cap's name and so
they can do whatever they want to the
all caps name right we're now under a
different jurisdiction of law until we
know who we are so I love the parallels
between law and spirituality because you
see like it really all is just a fractal
like a repeating pattern at different
levels so interesting let me try to
summarize then so there's a
um the old so the old The Liberation
from The Matrix or the old Earth Systems
is one one of the main ways is through
this
TDA is is through no longer in a way um
legally lawfully
identifying as the all caps name and
also as the all caps
Corporation and then this that's so
that's kind of um Liberation from the um
the the old Earth Systems and then
there's um the kind of the the the
body's um playful functionality in
building the new Earth architectures
infrastructures Systems basic needs that
and so then there's the sort of uh you
can do you can do both if both yeah yeah
public and private would be what that's
called the all caps name only functions
in the public that's the corporate realm
the legal realm but in the private is
like the living man on the land the
actual living entity that breathes and
has existence that's the private and the
public is not allowed to infringe on the
private that's also part of law you just
have to be able to establish that you're
living in the private so like having
your money in trusts versus corporate
bank accounts is one way a trust is a
private
uh it's trust law is the highest
jurisdiction of law for a number of
reasons but it's the most protected form
of law because it's the highest
jurisdiction so whatever assets you put
into a trust for example I mean it's
even called trust right has like a very
righteous frequency to it right you're
entrusting your asset into that trust
and so nobody can come in and pierce
your trust and claim your asset because
you actually gave it to the trust like
let's say all the money I own I'm going
to put it in a trust for my son one day
once I put that money in the trust I
can't like take it back out again if
it's an irrevocable trust so this is
like a very Noble honorable thing to do
it's a very Noble way to pass down your
assets to your children in future
generations and that's what the wealthy
Elite families have done for a long time
by the way roths child and Rockefellers
they have huge financial Empires because
they're not starting from scratch every
new generation every family for probably
a thousand years in those family groups
has pass down their wealth to their
children through trusts so every
generation builds on what their parents
did and after even just a few
Generations but you know let's say
probably a few dozen at least these
families have trillions of dollars in
their um portfolios because they've been
accumulating it for so long so like you
and I can wake up to that and do that
too and start passing down to our
children what we've collected In Our
Lifetime and that's another spiritual
parallel of humanity evolves by passing
down wisdom and sacred knowledge to the
children and raising the children up to
walk in the way of light and love so
that they can build on where we went and
every generation gets successively a
little better than the previous that's
uh the natural way of things so we've
also been thrown into a matrix where
it's like every generation is cut off
from the previous and starts from
scratch and that's another kind of
picture of how like the fact that we
don't live very long makes it hard for
our species to
evolve also because we have to start
over every generation back from poverty
you know and we're all in debt like
crazy in this country um we we can't
really get ahead and truly build a life
of fun and play and abundance and have
our needs met we have to be in the rat
race of the nine-to-five job and working
just to barely pay your rent that's the
Matrix if anything is is being plugged
into that system that's all based on
debt fake money fake corporations
deception fraud that's what the legal
system is based out of all Illusions but
you buy into it you know you play that
game and so you're going to Bear the
karmic consequences of playing it so
right now inh humanity is Breaking Free
from this matrix it's a challenge only
because so many people are still plugged
into the Matrix so when you try to leave
the public and live in the private I
keep all my money I keep all my assets
and trusts um I don't use big bank
accounts anymore cuz the more and more
we move towards this they're doing more
and more shady stuff with your money cuz
technically it's your all caps name
money not yours so they can do whatever
they want with it so I'm trying to exit
the system as much as possible by not
identifying as the all caps name perfect
spiritual parallel so like when a really
wealthy person does business like a
billionaire they're not doing their own
taxes right they're not doing their own
accounting they pay somebody to do their
accounting and that person acts as their
agent right that person acts as their
financial agent so they are are allowed
to sign financial documents in the name
of the billionaire
CEO in that same way you and I can claim
to be the Agents of that all caps name
account because who's going to rebut
me nobody and one of the 10 maxims of
law says an unrebutted affidavit an
affidavit is a statement of Truth an
unrebutted affidavit stands as fact
under the law so you could literally say
I'm a green monkey sign it have it
notorized after 90 days if nobody buts
you you could walk into court and claim
to be a green monkey and they have to
take it as fact That's How Strong an
affidavit is so if you claim to be the
agent of the all caps name account
you're claiming hey I have full rights
to act as the financial agent of that
instrument who disagrees crickets 90
days boom now under the law it's a fact
so now I can sign debts away on behalf
of that all Cap's name that's called
discharging where I can do these things
to where I now now technically have
access to that infinite bank account I
can't actually like get a credit card
and like use it as infinite money
they'll never do that they'll never give
you a credit card but you can use it to
discharge liabilities and debts because
again they have only ever loaned you
your money so when you try to hold them
on that fact they have to eventually
acquest to the truth they'll fight you
every way to the through the court
system but eventually the truth will
always win so you gain this confidence
as you practice living in the private
living under common law not commercial
law where you're like yeah no the truth
really is on my side I really don't have
anything to fear from these big bully
corporations and Banks and stuff they
have no truth on their side so why
should I be afraid and then the fear of
going to court over these things starts
to go away and in fact you kind of look
forward to it because you're like oh
they want to take me to court like I
know all of their dirty secrets let's go
to court let's talk to a judge about
this and see how they feel because
everything that they're doing is called
Securities fraud and there's huge
penalties for it so right now of course
this isn't being reported on the news at
all and never will be but there's dozens
of people that are suing you know the
credit bureaus credit card companies
banks for tens and 20ies of millions of
dollars and winning these huge bags from
court because they're catching the banks
on all their violations of UCC law and
again literally everything the bank does
is fraud every step they make along the
way to write you a presentment to give
it to you to take your money it's all
fraud because you were never given
disclosure they never told you what's
happening and so that's why they can be
penalized you know almost infinitely for
everything they do and then you show up
to court and you're like I have 150
documented violations of federal law and
the bank's like well we can't prove them
wrong so we got to pay up and I think
this movement is just kind of beginning
but it's growing so fast to the extent
that like two years ago when I just
started learning about this I could
barely find a video to educate me about
this stuff the legal fiction and all
that and just like two years later
there's entire YouTube channels popping
up teaching this stuff I'm a part of
three different law communities where
I've discharged all kinds of things so
like the proof is in the pudding like
you just got to start doing this stuff
to start realizing how true it is and to
me that's the real waking up to the
Matrix and it starts with the affidavit
well that's one it can start with number
of different steps man there's so many
ways to get remedy but to me you really
wake up truthfully from The Matrix when
you start doing it actually sending
those letters actually doing discharges
and seeing it work you're like wow the
whole system really is a scam right it's
too big of an idea to grasp before you
have some living proof from your own
experience but once you're like yo I
just took out I just bought a $100,000
car and didn't pay for it the system is
fake right
right interesting so there's that whole
swath of Breaking Free of the old Earth
and um and through what you've been
describing and then so what is your uh
we can we can wrap with this what is
your most exciting um focus on New Earth
builds and whatnot yeah oh juicy
question mhm I'm honestly I'm excited
about everything man like what you
shared lights me up I love that idea so
much I love the idea of like free energy
finally being available which we've had
for so long probably since before Tesla
um because free energy would literally
solve like every conceivable problem you
know on planet Earth so that's exciting
um that's why I lit up when you
mentioned it um but even like the basic
Awakening to the fact that there is
systemic corruption on our planet that
needs to be dealt with is super exciting
um because to me healing is exciting
it's like we don't even know what's
going to emerge on the other side of
this giant Collective healing we're
doing starting to hold our leaders
accountable starting to replace them
with better leaders starting to create
systems that don't need leadership at
all that run autonomously through Unity
those are all super exciting to me so I
just want to be an agent of change in
the best way whether that's just
spreading awareness kind of like I do
now of like teaching some of the common
law stuff like I just want to put this
on y'all's radar and then you go
research it you go do it myself I'm not
going to be that guy who like walks
people through processes but I am an
awareness raiser in that sense and I I
feel like shouting this from the
mountaintops because it is Humanity
salvation like think about the fact that
nobody in our country or in Canada or
the UK or Australia any of these
countries that do use this system I'm
describing nobody's actually in
debt and yet debt is how they're
enslaved right by the government and
Banks and stuff it's called debt slavery
or Usery from goes back to the
Babylonian times enslaving somebody
through debt Usery that's what's being
done to humanity right now and the truth
is no one's in debt everyone's worth
more money than they can conceive of you
know you're a being of infinite worth is
actually true so much so that the banks
know it's true and they collateralized
your infinite worth without you knowing
it right you know it's it's pretty
amazing corate interesting um now would
you would you say that um um are are
there like repercussions of sorts that
you um see with if one does not do that
sort of um Liberation from oldw World um
contractive contractions um and let's
say they just go and begin getting even
more deeply involved in um in basic
needs infrastructures and new earth
building and homesteading with these new
mechanisms and whatnot do they still
have to do some sort of uh at least like
some sort of avid davit or something
absolutely of the old yeah because if
you don't you're leaving the hooks in
you from the Matrix where they can pull
that chain anytime they want okay so if
you're homesteading let's say in the
future but you haven't done that like
what could happen then oh they could
take your property they could do
whatever because under their contracts
everything is contract law in in the
legal world it's all contracts because
it's all business if you already have
the land and you already have the home
on the land and it's all already
legally it's legal owned by the all caps
name not the living man Atlas okay so
you have to establish who you are versus
the all caps name that they own one of
the maximums so as long as you establish
yourself as a living as a living man yes
that did you say what what the all caps
name that is what the all caps name that
is it's just yeah it own what is it it
owns or what like the agent of oh the
agent of yeah like Mark Zuckerberg to
Facebook you become Mark Zu Zuckerberg
is to Facebook as to your legal fiction
to your corporation oh you become like
the CEO of your corporation oh okay okay
so so you can sign things on its behalf
all that so you do that you become the
the agent of the fiction yeah and then
now there's no hook in a way okay so
then if there was the hook is you are
the legal fiction so you're our property
because one of the maxims of law says
that which one creates One controls so
they made your corporation of birth not
you it's their corporation but you can
claim to be the president of that
Corporation and they can't say you're
not because they're a fake as long as
you're the living man of the of the
symbolized fiction mhm of because under
natural law dude nobody can punish you
at all for anything unless you've
provably done harm to someone so like
this is one of the ways people are
getting out of speeding tickets I just
watched a video on this the other day
this guy did a brilliant job he got a
speeding ticket and he was like who's
the injured party he said are we under
criminal jurisdiction or uh commercial
jurisdiction or Civic jurisdiction and
she's like this is a a criminal
jurisdiction he like okay great so
please tell me who the injured party is
because there's no crime without an
injured party and she was like uh and
she deflected him a few times and he was
like I'm here for on a crime tell me who
my injured party is who did I harm and
she goes the state of Texas and he was
like will Mr state of Texas please stand
up and represent yourself and she tries
to throw him off and he's like no I have
the right to stand before my accuser
under the law where's Mr state of Texas
and state of Texas is a corporation that
doesn't exist so he can't face his
accuser because he didn't do anyone harm
he broke a corporate policy to not drive
over 50 miles hour interesting and if
they can say he's the all caps name he's
a bad employee who broke a corporate
policy so pay up employee so you're
saying I'm not the employee the
corporation that you made I'm the agent
of it right so I have legal um
protection against it right right right
interesting so that's all anybody has to
do it's called status correction there's
this um kind of the um going into the
the dimension of things that are the law
dimension of things and in that that law
in that law Dimension um it's
fascinating because it's it's it's it
does have a very uh cool um spiritual
analog in a way totally going kind of um
um uh kind of be beyond the center point
contraction and the Centerpoint
contraction is so deeply affiliated with
that symbolic name that was stamped on
corporatized um and and turn and and so
so okay so the so then in the new Earth
there's uh there's both building the
future homesteading basic needs
abundance and freedom and there's also
um being the living man or woman the
agent of yeah that uh uh fictional
leaving the system leaving the Matrix
right unplug yourself you go and all you
have to do to unplug yourself is declare
who you are like you have the right to
self-determination nobody can tell you
who you are um so like people do this in
court they're like who's the claimant
who's claiming I'm the all Cap's name
I'm claiming I'm not prove it somebody
prove it and nobody will show up ever to
prove it because it's all corporations
that don't exist
so it's a beautiful parallel and just
it's all corporations that don't exist
it's all these yeah these stories these
names it's literally a matrix these
bounds that don't exist that don't exist
titles and names of corporations that
don't have any reality at all people
speak on their behalf and pretend to be
them but aren't
right perfect spiritual parallel perfect
yeah a perfect uh wrapping I feel like
that's that's so so cool yeah wow it's
fascinating that the the bounds
themselves have such deep ties to that
kind of that corporate corporative
nature yeah um and
uh and then that there's that there's
that um that uh that the living man or
woman as the agent of that but into the
boundless new Earth architectures no
hooks free abundant mhm let's go baby
let's go one of my favorite lines in the
course of Miracle says all creation is
extension so that's why again like
Humanity as a whole has built these
corrupt systems because they're
extensions of us anything we create at
any level has to reflect the human ego
because that's the where the collectives
at heavily identified with the ego right
so of course all of our banks and
governments and corporations and
everyone acts like a big freaking ego at
every level
because creation is extension so that's
why when you and I transcend the false
nature and step into our true awareness
of who we are then we can create like
ourselves now which is the new Earth
right we create an infinitely
sustainable abundant free world which is
a reflection of who we are we are free
we are abundant we have infinite value
already there's already No Lack of
anything but we have to create a world
that reflects that reality and so how
can we create that world if we don't
become it first if we don't know it
first so that's why the Awakening is
always in here but I'll I'll give this
preface as we close because whenever I
talk about common law I want to give
this
disclaimer typically people will rush
into doing these processes before
they've really studied up enough and
before they actually embody these truths
so they'll get really angry for example
when they find out about the legal
fiction they're like I can't believe
that dirty government made a fake
Corporation out of my name how dare they
I'm going to take it back back and they
come from this anger energy they're
looking for a fight those are the people
who always get dragged into court before
they're ready before they have their
documents and they get steamrolled by
the court system right so what I say is
before you enact anything to correct
your status to discharge debt any of
that come to peace with the fact that
this is the way the world is yes it's An
Inconvenient Truth but the TR knowing
the truth will set you free and when
you're finally at peace with this and
you have nobody to go to war against
you're just like I just want to declare
what's true I'm not that Corporation I
know that I believe that I want to let
the system know that now then from that
energy of like self-confidence
self-belief peace I come in peace not to
War I submit my documents from that
energy you'll always have things go the
way you're looking for right you'll
manifest the outcomes you're looking for
when your energy is right so this is all
about embodiment it's not just about
head knowledge I know a lot of people
that can Razzle Dazzle me with laws I
can't believe how much law they know and
yet they've been hosed in court by the
bank so many times because they went
looking for a fight and that's what
courts need is that fighting conflict
energy that's what the ego needs right
so it's like what Jesus says in that one
line agree with your adversary quickly
is one of the tips he gives and then he
says lest he lest your adversary hand
you over to the sheriff and the sheriff
hand you to the judge and the judge
throw you in prison so even in Jesus's
day 2,000 years ago like he understood
how the system worked he's like don't
fight the system man that's what they
want you to do you know come in peace uh
to do no harm be as wise as serpents but
innocent as doves right and if someone
accuses you of something agree with them
that's the conditional acceptance of I
will lawfully pay any debts I lawfully
owe I agree you just need to prove it to
me and then we're just putting the truth
back on those who are trespassing the
truth and the truth sets itself free
right MH
yeah
mhm
cool wow it's been so beautiful this is
the first uh in-person
podcast of the show in Austin that's
right and I'm honored man we got
uh we got to share it I think we dropped
in a little bit Yeah from Al Haas to
Legal fictions and nothing everything's
backed by nothing yeah so beautiful
well-rounded podcast yeah really fun wow
yeah and we'll get to we'll get to
explore more um in the in the network
here I'm I'm looking forward to that cuz
you've been established here for a bit
now like yeah what has it been a a year
and a half yeah a couple years so it's
exciting um let's let's see how we can
how we can connect out here and and um
and yeah it's been so exciting like
hearing about these new communities that
are being built around here too and and
um getting the chance to Shepherd and
Homestead with those we've had a bunch
of you fun in the in the live chat too
um there been some great energy and
comments there only imagine yeah yeah
thanks everyone so much for tun yeah
thanks for hanging out with us we really
appreciate it and um there's been some
comments from people
that watch both of our our channels and
whatnot and they're just like really
excited that this came together again
yeah super fun um cool so there's um you
know there's links uh below to Aaron's
uh YouTube channel to his website you
can find more information there and um
and probably more content on the
subjects that Aaron was that Aaron was
sharing in fact I have a series on my
YouTube channel if anyone's like really
is it a playlist it's a playlist yeah
everything in my channel is playlists
what is it that one called so you go to
my channel playlist Tab and then it's
called The Rabbit Hole okay and it's
like an eight part series I did with a
co- facilitator friend of mine where we
go from A to Z through that entire
subject the history of this is this is
those are the videos that I saw bits of
okay yeah I saw bits of those so it's
called The Rabbit Hole the rabbit hole
okay cuz I when I I remember seeing
content pop up where you were talking
about this and it was exciting yeah yeah
it's fun uh it is really fun it's like
yeah it's in a way it is like uh
obsoleting the old embarking into the
new and just being jazzed about just how
beautiful that whole the freedom of it
all is and how it appears and how just
just the Indescribable yeah none of us
have any idea how beautiful and holy and
epic the new world can be and will be
that we're going to create like all we
know is this super corrupt system right
right like we can barely even imagine a
truly free United world and it it
surpasses our ability to imagine it
that's how good it is so there's a lot
to be excited about yeah let's go let's
freaking go let's freaking go gosh that
freedom and play in innocence of the
kids are those basic needs being met man
it's just like like how do we want to
play today baby how do we want to play
today that's kind of what my life feels
like now yes I'm sure yours does too yes
and more and more so for for the whole
for abundant
prosperous yeah um all right that's uh
that's that's a WAP um much love thanks
again uh everyone for tuning in thanks
so much Aaron thanks again for coming on
man dude thank you so much for having me
man super pleasure I'll come back
anytime I'm looking forward to it man
yeah this will be fun the the baptism of
Austin yes and it's in person guest has
begun I'm honored to Harald your arrival
here by the way thank you
that's so
beautiful all right that's a wrap folks
peace oh we got some balloon animation
yay OBS does these it's so cool it's so
cool when it does I got to still figure
out how it how it does I got to figure